this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'll talk
little bit about myself and what led me
to apply for the drear in the first
place why I chose urban agriculture and
then i'll talk about Rosario Argentina
and Cuba where I spent most of my time
and then we'll tie it up with some
lessons from these places so first a
little bit about me I grew up with a
hard-working single mom that worked very
hard to put a good meal on the table
every night and I every day came home
and was so excited to sit with her and
to talk about my day and to eat a great
meal and as I grew older I realized that
not everybody gets that and as I learned
more about it's a little nervous okay
and as I grew older I realized that not
everybody gets that and the iniquities
in the food system became a focus of
mine as I grew older and so I came to
Cornell and wanted to learn more about
the specific horticultural principles
behind food production so that I could
apply them to my work and food justice
as an adult so why a burn agriculture
while I was at Cornell I became really
interested in urban agriculture in
particular because I saw it as a way to
really focus on food deserts and
inequities in this in the food
production system and in my research I I
knew that there were a number of
positive things that ruin agricultural
did for communities aside from just
making green space the first is it
provides an economic stimulus and this
happens in a number of ways one is that
you know if you have families that are
farming in the city there's a lot of
little micro enterprises that develop so
maybe somebody's going to make compost
somebody else is going to maybe bring in
vermicompost somebody else is going to
be marketing and packaging so it
provides a lot of local economic
development which is really great more
most obviously it provides green space
spaces for recreation that's a good
places for recreation and community
gathering but there are a lot of you
know you take abandoned lots and
bring in more economic and agro
ecological principles to those places
obviously biodiversity is a big benefit
and the microclimate that's created can
help to really cool cities as well this
last part is the social peace so not
only does a green spaces and provide
economic stimulus to it to a community
but it brings communities together and
in a lot of cities all over the world
where urban agriculture is a movement
it's really socially inclusive it
usually involves a lot of discriminated
and marginalized people a lot of women
older workers disabled people maybe
people who have come to a new city and
they don't have access to purchasing
power capital so it's a social network
and the social net for people so with
all of that research I you know and
knowledge that i had about urban
agriculture i really wanted to
experience it firsthand so with the
generous support of marvin who was my
advisor as an undergrad he really
encouraged me to apply so that i could
develop as a young urban agriculture
list so in my research as i was applying
for the drear rosario argentina kept
coming up over and over again a place
that i had never heard of and maybe most
of you haven't either it's a city of
about 1 million just a few hours north
of Buenos Aires and and as I was reading
more and more about it I realized that
it it seemed like a very well
established system there seemed like a
very strong network of farms it was very
well documented in academic literature
and not only were the articles about
Rosario really interesting but articles
that pointed to other countries programs
in Latin America always referred back to
Rosario so it seemed like a really good
model for urban agriculture and the are
you AF is the resource centers for urban
agriculture and food security
and that was one of the main sources
that I used when I was trying to figure
out where I wanted to go a lot of really
great articles and research that have
been done on urban farms and they're
really committed to poverty reduction so
I was really interested in what they had
to say and they really praised the work
that was done in Rosario and lastly I
saw that they had won the dubai
international award for best practices
which was an award that the united arab
emirates and the UN conceived to award
communities that were doing work to
support the greening and Riaan visioning
of green spaces or making green spaces
and making communities more
environmentally sustainable so seemed
like a good choice so some backstory on
Argentina to put the program in context
is that um the history of Argentina is
so complicated then I was trying to make
this slide I had actually really
difficult time but these are the the big
bullet points so for its in 1976 through
83 there was a pretty powerful dictator
who and that period was known as the
dirty war and during that time there
were a lot of atrocities and the
economic development that had sort of
prospered for three decades was
overturned in a matter of a few short
years and so quickly after the
dictatorship the company or the country
was pushed into a period of you know
high unemployment large you know food
insecurity and that period they were you
know from 84 to 89 the country was
really recovering from the dictatorship
but they didn't it took its I think
they're still recovering in a lot of
ways so in the mid 90s a few farmers
that had migrated from the north and the
inland of Argentina started to form
gardens in the in the outskirts of
Rosario and that was a difficult time
there were a lot of in the there were a
lot of farmers who migrated by the
thousands in the late 80s and early 90s
and when they arrived in Rosario they
found that there wasn't as much work as
promised
and they didn't really have a way of
earning capital and so slums developed
and it was in those slums that they
started gardening and then in 2001 there
was another dramatic economic depression
that was begun by the peso which was
devalued overnight to about a quarter
it's worth so after that the Argentine
the municipality in Rosario saw what was
happening in these in these marginalized
areas where people were gardening and
they immediately sanctioned it and said
yes this is a legitimate use of space
and we want to do everything we can to
support it so so then they had the
support of the municipality and very
quickly I'm by 2004 when the dubai
international award was given there were
10,000 families that were involved in
over 750 community gardens so blew up
very quickly and really provided support
to families during economic crisis so
the structure of the program now as it
was when i was there is that there's a
seed bank right which is right downtown
and the seed bank is called neon daroga
which is guarani one of the indigenous
languages and it means our house so
that's the seed bank which is run by one
of the founders and then there are 7
parque aware fest and the where tests
are large orders that were created in
the late 2000s so they move from a
system of small little gardens to a few
of those and then also these very large
where tests which i think the average
where it is probably about three or four
acres and then those are cooperatively
run with probably 20 to 30 farmers /
huerta and then the produce is sold at
the gardens it's also brought to market
stands all over the city and then the
municipality helped to build a structure
in downtown rosario that processes all
of the extra vegetables that they want
to sell to businessmen you know licked
salads on there wait break from work and
they also use medicinal herbs and
botanicals
to create like lotions and soaps things
like that to bring it a little bit of
extra money so those are the big points
and then the capacity-building I wanted
to mention because what they do every
monday is that's actually yeah yeah sure
every monday there's a capacity-building
session at the municipality and at each
of the we're toast there's a farmer that
is given the role they call them promote
daughters and that promoter basically is
the liaison between the municipality and
all of the farm workers so they try to
keep it as horizontal as possible they
really provide training for the promoter
and that training could be anything from
making you know fermented or
biopesticides to how to incorporate
vermiculture all these things and then
the promoters work with their farmers to
to achieve that and those
capacity-building sessions took place
every monday and i was there that's part
of my role so I when I was in Argentina
I participated in those sessions every
Monday and for the most part I was in
the role of farmer just kind of at the
sessions learning as much as I could
mostly using that as a time to work on
my Spanish and figure out which words I
knew and which words I needed to study
and and then also the rest of the days
of the week tuesday through friday i was
assigned to one of the park i worked us
and i just farmed every day with with
the where taters and this is the Huerta
that I worked at it was called la abuela
um and it was about a mile outside of
the city center what you can't see is a
slaughterhouse it was like right here
and I won't talk about that right now
but it was a daily experience at the
farm so we can so I there were two other
interns that worked with me and Rosario
that was pure coincidence I arrived the
same week that a young man from france
and young man from brazil arrived which
was really nice it gave a lot of
structure
to the internship since there were three
of us so they really went through a good
effort to make sure that we were at
every meeting and were able to really
participate in everything that happened
with the program of urban agriculture so
we did a lot of things on the farm many
of which I hadn't actually done before
even though i have loved farming for so
long like we saved seeds almost on the
daily so this is us saving some they're
called zappa sheet though like a little
like a little Argentine squash seed and
so I learned a lot about different
methods for seed saving and and then we
would this is a just a little picture of
lots of different seeds that we had
saved herbs and beans and then one of
the things that the program did really
well was really market itself and put
themselves out in the community to try
to tell people and make themselves known
as much as possible so this was an event
by the river one day and it was actually
a 3-day thing where we had 50 farmers
and just I think it was I mean many
different sections of tables where the
variety of fruits and vegetables was
available and if this were here I maybe
wouldn't seem as radical but in
Argentina they eat a lot of meat and a
lot of pasta and the idea of eating
vegetables even next to your me is not
as like it's not the we don't it's not
thought of in the way that I think of it
here so this was a really new movement
it almost felt like Rosario was
experiencing the kind of an Argentine
and a whole was where we were with
vegetarianism and you know fresh
vegetables organic produce it was almost
like going back ten years or maybe even
15 so so that was interesting to feel
that you know people still asking like
what's the vegetarian or what is like
how do i cook this so there was a lot of
educational opportunities while we were
there as well so the other country that
I visited was Cuba which was a really
obvious choice for me I knew that if I
was going to study urban agriculture in
Latin America that I had to go to Cuba
and so I saved it for last
and while we're looking at this map so
the when I was in row sorry I worked
every day with the program of urban
agriculture which was housed by the
municipality and that was really
positive because it gave me a lot of
structure and I was able to ask all the
questions I needed to and see as much as
I wanted to but it also was kind of
difficult because there were days maybe
when I really wanted to work or go to
the farm but they didn't want ear so we
didn't or something was closed or so my
schedule really depended on their
schedule so in Cuba because the garden I
mean there are obviously a lot of
gardens in hermana but their gardens all
over the cut the island in different
cities so I took a really different
approach in Cuba and so I started in
Havana flew into Havana and I took an
overnight bus to Guantanamo which is
down here and I stayed in the city
called baracoa and then I made my way
back through different cities so we
stayed in Santiago de Cuba come away
ciego de avila via clara all the way
down and then i ended up over here as
well so so really different experience
she's really great ok so in order to put
this in context very quickly I think
many of you probably know that in Cuba
for 100 years sugar was king and there
was many of the forests were cleared to
make way for a mono crop of sugar which
was their major export crop for a very
long time and we all know this guy or I
think many of you know this guy which is
Norman Borlaug so he initiated the green
revolution obviously after he grew his
short varieties of wheat and Cuba was
very quick to adopt the practices that
he and his team's really pushed and it
worked really well with sugar and so
Cuba very quickly became highly
mechanized they were extremely dependent
on pesticides
herbicides in order to have their export
crop and actually even though it was
working really well there was this group
of scientists that were very skeptical
of what Cuba was doing and of how they
were so blindly following these
processes or practices and a small group
of scientists actually began studying I
p.m. and in the 80s which I thought was
very cool and so when the Soviet
collapsed there Cuba was actually poised
very well to deal with it for a few
reasons one is that they had already
been doing research in these areas of
alternative agriculture or you know and
more natural like cultural practices but
also something that I learned which I
thought was so incredible is that
despite the fact that Cuba only has two
percent of Latin America's population
they have eleven percent of its
scientists which is still true today and
so they were they were able to harness
all of that knowledge and infrastructure
to do research and development and just
apply it to this so when the Soviet
collapse that was 89 literally overnight
they lost eighty percent of their
imports and their ability to export so
they lost fuel they couldn't transport
food from the roar areas to the cities
they lost I think three quarters of
their imported food or of their food
which three-quarters of it was imported
and so Cuba had a lot to do in a very
short amount of time and with the
decreased imports they had to increase
food production which was just like a
startling equation like it's hard to
figure out like how they did that and
how they so part of the way that they
did that was that across the whole
island not just in the urban areas they
divided large estates up into smaller
parcels and every couple years those
parcels kept getting smaller and smaller
so they went from many many many
thousands down to 1,000 few years later
they ended up being I think
50 acres or Hector's with the max and so
there as far as urban agriculture and
cube is concerned there's four different
types of farms the first is called oh my
gosh the co-operative farms so this is a
the most famous example this is called
vivado a llamar de vero means greenhouse
but they just applied it so Lovato
al-ahmad is in is in al-ahmad which is
one of those suburbs of Havana it
started out as just maybe 20 hectares
and is now 100 Hector's or more it
employs over 200 work here dozin and
they use the organo Pony co structure
but they also have animals they make
their own vermicompost they graph their
own fruit trees they have grown neem
trees which have proven to be a really
awesome form of pesticide and they have
along with the rest of Cuba have
remembered old cultural practices such
as you know crop rotation they use wind
breaks all of the stuff that we know
about and you know our proponents of so
that's that's one part or version of a
farm and what's open I yet so the thing
that makes this farm unique is that
these because it's a cooperative a lot
of people come together to work on it
and then they share the profits when you
in Cuba if you wanted if you if you knew
that there was empty land and you wanted
to form a cooperative you'd go to them
you say like hey we see that lot we want
it and then they would provide for you
the seeds the market stand every input
that you could need in the beginning but
then the idea is that over time you're
producing your own see do you have your
own animals everything becomes
sustainable so the second is the organo
Pony coast it's just a raised bed with
organic methods and
but this a lot of the organ upon ekos
were and our state built and run and so
a lot of them are really really high
input Cuba is really proud of them and
they are the poster child for get or
urban agriculture in Cuba but they're
certainly not the like the greatest
portion of food production but but
they're they're very beautiful their
pristine no weeds just absolutely
gorgeous and they you find organic
Pawnee goes in lots of different corners
that you wouldn't expect which is really
neat but the takeaway from me is is like
very very expensive to build very high
input and so because of that despite you
know the fact that other versions of
farms maybe are more productive or more
and socially inclusive this is the
version that Cuba always shows the world
because this is what they're most proud
of so so this third type of urban farm
is an institutional farm which most of
this all of the schools and pretty much
most places where people work are run by
the government so factories schools any
kind of government building if there's
land attached to it often that land is
turned into a farm and the people that
work at the factories or the buildings
are expected to work on the farm to
produce food for themselves for lunches
which is an it's a really cool model so
this is a picture of just edit one of
the schools so the last and my favorite
was the parse Ellis or patios and this
was the most common and most effective
and important version of urban
agriculture in Cuba but it's not what
they're as proud of because it's you
know it there's no investment on their
part but the parcel is our rainy a
couple different styles there's
obviously you know if somebody they're
called patios partly because a lot of
people utilize their patios and use you
know buckets or tires or whatever they
can find to plant food there I included
this photo and there's a few more after
because this was my
favorite farm that I visited that was a
parcela and it was in kind of see
there's these buildings here and then
there's a road and then this is a pretty
steep decline and then it just kind of
like cuts off here and there's the sea
so this man's name was Orlando and he
lived in one of the homes right across
the street and had for most of his life
and he kept looking over and this entire
area was just covered in trash and he he
just looked at it one day and said like
I'm going to fix that so he cleared he
spent a year clearing the trash and then
spent another year creating these tears
and then started planting so the next
photos from the other side looking out
so literally I mean it just drops off
pretty precarious location it's so
beautiful and such a good example of how
you can use marginal lands to really
provide food and beauty for your
community fermenting herbs super common
I don't remember which herb that was
actually but quick tika and this is
orlando and his son and the long buddy
Colt order right here this is the
vermicompost area so it was really
complete which was neat and this is a
really common image we saw these
everywhere so I'll the the amazing thing
about Cuba I mean the gardens were
incredible but what they really
represented was this just unfathomable
and bottomless imagination and the
ingenuity and creativity of the Cuban
people in so many ways was the most
beautiful thing and so this man had
bought a bicycle what a lot of them did
was they were able to get these like
attachments from Cuba or from China
excuse me that were pretty cheap I think
that they were coming in on the black
market and so people who welded they
would like go to their well dear friend
and this Chinese like attachment would
be multi welded onto their
bicycle and then they would build it up
so so this was you know a man who went
to the urban farm got stuff in the
morning and then drove around so it was
empty an example of a micro-enterprise
we go back really so the other version
of the bike that we would see everywhere
was if there was imagine that this car
is not here or these shelves are not
here and then there's just a bench so bc
taxis everywhere which is really cool so
one of the things I was really surprised
to learn about Cuba I think I had
revered it for so long and their gardens
for so long that I imagine that all
Cubans supported it and thought it was
great and that's not the case so within
the government there are two opposing
beliefs one side is the people who work
in the office of City Planning and urban
planning and then the other side is the
people who work from the NAG of the
Ministry of Agriculture the City
Planning folks really think that you
know the urban AG in the city centers
has been really awesome and helpful but
that you know the crisis is over now so
we should use those lands to bring in
business and whereas the men AG people
think like oh no no this is working this
is beautiful we want to keep this for
our communities and so I mean this is
the question that I think a lot of
people are asking as far as urban AG
goes you might have connected the dots
but in Rosario and in Cuba both of these
amazing networks of urban farms were
created out of crisis and so the idea is
how do we maintain them when the crisis
is over do they just disappear were they
just helpful for that period of time or
can we really make this a permanent
fixture in our communities so the
takeaway the takeaway is that I hope
that there's that we can keep them that
we can not only keep them but that we
can bring urban agriculture two cities
everywhere and to food deserts
everywhere that we can use urban
agriculture to make our cities more
beautiful and tuner
our communities and to create spaces for
us to enjoy each other's company the
other take away which was one that I
didn't really expect for myself because
I had mostly focused on horticulture and
production and sort of on the ground
stuff was that in both of these cases
and in a lot of other cases that I'd
seen or heard about when I was in South
America or in Cuba government support
was really important the government
support is what made both of them
possible and not big government but the
municipalities and so it was easier to
do when I was home but to really compare
like okay what what did the municipality
in Rosario and the government of Cuba
offered it that made this possible and
there were a lot of different things one
is the you know they provided economic
incentives for example so in Rosario not
only did they map the land as they did
in Cuba and show where all of the empty
urban lots were but in Rosario they the
municipality raised taxes on urban lands
that were unused so that way if you had
our Midland urban land that you owned
and you were not making it available to
an urban farmer and you weren't using it
yourself all of a sudden you had to pay
a lot more money so they incentivized
urban farming in that way another
important mechanism that municipalities
use is design obviously if a community
is designed with a space for a garden
there will be a garden education is an
important component as well the
municipality and the Cuban government
they trained farmers and they had really
large educational communication
campaigns where they taught people about
urban farming and they taught people
about how important nutrition is and and
all of the benefits of having urban
farms in their community so certainly
it's possible without municipality
support and we see it here of little
pockets of it happening in our country
and abroad but when you have
municipality support or local government
support they can bring
together you know different stakeholders
so you can have big conversations with
you know the municipalities with
nonprofits with the actors with the
urban farmers with design with you know
local universities and so I think that
you know for me sort of what I've
figured out is that I want to know more
about that I don't I didn't know a lot
about that before I went to Cuba and I
think that if I'm going to be a person
who works now in the u.s. in my
community to make a stronger urban
agriculture network wherever I live that
I want to know about policy because I
think that it's really useful as a tool
to to making permanent spaces like this
so I've been looking into graduate work
at Tufts school of nutrition because
they have a really cool program that
combines applied nutrition with food
policy so I see that as a really good
thing to sort of add to my my basket of
tools and I recently co-wrote a grant I
where I'm working in Providence to build
a garden on a school which is really
exciting and I'll be able to finally
apply some of the stuff that I've
learned at Cornell and abroad and I just
see myself working in marginalized
communities here in the states and I'm
so grateful that I've had the
opportunity to not only practice my
Spanish because most of the communities
have been working in our here are
largely spanish-speaking but I feel
really yeah this is a good time to I'm
really grateful thank you to the drear
committee first because I this
experience has been so invaluable and I
feel like it really informed me and will
continue to inform the way but I
existing community in the future
Jonathan Russell anneli is not here but
he loves soil and he loves urban soil
and has been a really great mentor for
me as well Phil McMichael how many
anywhere he's awesome and his class in
international development taught me so
much about the historical roots of
poverty
and food insecurity and how we can think
about that and frame our lives within
that context and that undoubtedly also
helped me when I was abroad and thinking
about urban farming and lastly I want to
thank my family because they were so
supportive throughout this entire year
particularly my husband who provides me
just an endless joy and support thank
you all for coming that's my year
so what's your sense of for about how
well people are fed throughout the
country and secondly a proportion of
food comes from these sort of urban
center versus grown on larger farms out
what so before I went to Cuba actually
read that's the second statistic which
is um with how much produced in city and
how much people eating and in Havana for
example over eighty-five percent of
what's of the vegetables that are eaten
in the city are produced in the city and
that is consistent in the cities across
the island so that gives you this idea
that people are just like feasting on
vegetables right and that was correct so
I mean when when we went there and
across the whole island be the food
security was so tangible I mean there
were no grocery stores pretty much
anywhere so and the food rations you
know you would see people just lined up
every morning and so even though there
is this amazing network and that there
are so many vegetables provided they're
still there it's still not really enough
so that's part of the reason why I
really hope that they don't move those
gardens out to make space for other
businesses because I'm not really sure I
mean I guess it must they're planning on
gathering more food imports
you should talk about the week i
remember that this man has been mad you
that's where the week i suppose it was
really it's a good interesting question
because all all of their wheat and they
bake a lot there's a lot of bread
products is a lot of then you see that
in the streets and you see that and Cuba
has an eye color could cost up at the
cloud which is basically like a bed and
breakfast and so we stayed with families
the entire time we were there and
consistently first of all like all the
meals were basically the same right and
in every bed and breakfast it was like a
standard sort of meal they would cook
but a lot of them and there was a huge
portion of the meals that would always
consist of bread and all of their week
comes from Canada they don't actually
grow any week and there's nothing no
source of that kind of product it comes
from the island so it's like there's a
huge amount of bread that they're eating
and it all comes from abroad and a low
ration of vegetables which is all being
grilled domestically well also I am I
baked cookies and they are an Argentine
treat that I miss a lot so I figured I'd
bake them for you guys they're called
alpha hoarders and they're a butter corn
meal kind of cookie they're really
softer than they're filled with dulce de
leche so if you haven't had one yet you
can't some of yourself for that as well
so just in terms of just the drear how
little boys do to make all the
connections
it was a quick moment will took a long
time because I applied in March and then
I didn't leave till January and I when I
applied I had already been emailing
people for three or four months so it
was a solid year of sending out emails
and I sent out emails to people in so
many more cities and so it also it was
kind of you know perfect the city that
respondent was Rosario it was the model
um but even still there I would get like
a one-line kind of like sure but it
wasn't until I was actually there but I
just I basically just like walked into
the municipality building and I was like
hi like I'm here I want to you know be a
part of this what can I do and they
actually had me put together a
presentation in Spanish for the entire
program and and that was when I was
still doing my intensive Spanish classes
so I learned Central American Spanish
and in Argentina it's absolutely
different there's like six thousand
words that are different the
pronunciation is different and I felt
like I was a toddler all over again I
couldn't you know so right away I had to
you know give this big presentation and
it worked they liked me and they
immediately brought me in so that was
those a good test yeah yeah I felt like
it was pretty nerve-wracking but it yeah
so um but I sort of the Emmy may have
communicated enough with me that I
figured it was going to be a go but
there there was minimal communication I
think at least I can only speak for a
few of the cities but i think that
there's definitely this idea that like
face to face is what gets things done
they don't really I mean Cuba had no
email culture because most people don't
have access to the internet so that was
an absolutely like just walk in and
introduce myself to people how did you
find out about people just from
newspapers yeah and I had I had sort of
known about t-bo's one of those beacons
I think that I had sort of idolized once
I became interested in urban agriculture
and also you know but but in Cuba I mean
I knew the agency's I knew I even had
some names
i read that i couldn't get in touch with
anybody until I was there so so that was
a little bit more like waking up them so
you were like seven months from 90 to
North seven and then for the look yep
for people so because you compare the
diet between Argentina and cumulus but
people can we go today yeah absolutely
so in Argentina they are crazy about how
they're just like Ed twice a day so in
Argentina a typical meal would be like a
fried bread of some kind with a big
piece of meat and maybe like shaved
carrots like little shipyard and that
really typical they didn't really eat
breakfast it was a lot of bread so maybe
like a little Christmas morning with
coffee and then they ate a lot of pasta
too because they had a large migration
of Italians like 18 anymore too late so
so I mean a really big pasta culture and
not a lot of vegetables so in Rosario I
had been working there for five months
and I was at this I knew you know the
whole thing I I was at that some event
that the farmers put on this year so
it's a big luncheon with the farmers you
know they obviously grow everything
themselves produce it and they made this
huge lunch where they sold tickets so
they sold 100 or so tickets in a local
restaurant every year offers for free to
host the event so I'm at this event and
helping them and kind of like serving
and doing some mingling I took a lot of
photos for the program when I was there
to because they didn't have a lot of
good equipment so that was so I was
there and one of the women who works at
the program mentioned to me that it's
such a shame that they don't need the
vegetables and I was like wait a minute
why like that's wow that's what they eat
they grow this when I take
I need it and she was like no no no like
they don't like the vegetables they grow
them and sell them and then they buy
pasta and it broke my heart and I I
think that's you know that's part of the
reason why I really interested in
nutritionist because I know that there's
so many cultural there's so much more
than just you know access that
determines what people eat and how
healthy they are so that's Argentina
Cuba was really different after the
Soviet class during the special period
which was the food rationing period
we're just going on it became illegal to
for anybody to to kill a cow without
state approval so you never see the a
lot of me is really rare um so Cubans
will typically eat just rice and beans
and then whatever vegetables herbs that
they have and not a very big portions
and then as Micah said you know a lot of
bread the tourist thing is really
different though because unless you pay
to keep wherever you're staying at your
home then there's the separate network
of restaurants that is just for Taurus
and in those restaurants you can get
like beef and fish and all these things
and it's just like heartbreaking we
didn't even we couldn't go to those
places very much just because of the
ethical just didn't feel like to go and
feast and then to it walk outside and
see Cubans lined up for a bit of bread
you know just and because they provide
so much to the tourists they leave
themselves with just you know the
vegetables that they grow and these
things like that yeah
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu